what's your guy do you guys have a weird
thing that you guys know you could do
that you didn't work for that's just
like this is a thing that you could
check this out what
[Music]
so when I say Guinness World Record what
are the first things that come to your
mind [ __ ] it'll waste the time
losers no really that's the first thing
that comes to your mind all of them but
some of them it's like all right what
are you doing which record do you is
most prominent in your mind I actually
think losers and [ __ ] really cool
guys yeah cause it's both it's either
it's either it's the lamest [ __ ] ever or
it's the coolest [ __ ] ever someone that
did like a four minute mile or something
and you're like wow and then someone who
ate like a thousand Donuts well that's
actually pretty cool or like you know
like Rob Dyrdek he on on the show he put
like the longest like uh [ __ ] grind
on a pipe all the way down I'm like
that's really cool but if there's a guy
that's like I stopped 30 marshmallows
into my foreskin I'm like that's weird
it's like that's a record but and then
imagine I got the clipboard he's like
all right one I think those belong on
Ripley's Believe It or Not yeah and not
Guinness all right that is loser I don't
know how I yeah I don't know how I
stumbled upon this video but it was a
world record it was yesterday of a guy
who's like a nunchuck master and it was
how many consecutive ping pong balls he
could hit with them
it sounds cool but you watch it and
you're like what the [ __ ] is this
does he have the Bruce Lee swag no and
then he does it again with candles bro
with candles how many candles he can
take out the flame of a candle he could
take out with a nunchuck once again
sounds cool but the way he does it as
well like what the [ __ ] is this those
were only cool because of the Artistry
element not the actual practicality yeah
not everything's fun and that large it's
it's if if you can sense how much a
person masturbates
then you're like that is [ __ ] whack
so like you know what like the History
Channel That's Bart's measurement for
everything Guinness World Record by the
way like the History Channel right
the History Channel they're like [ __ ]
knife Wars or blade Wars but oh that's
pretty cool and you see the guy he's
like a former Navy SEAL oh that guy's
pretty cool then there's like another
dude that comes up like dude that guy
looks like jacks off four times a day
it's like a cold steel advertisement
they always get like the fattest [ __ ]
dude [ __ ] chopping up all the stuff
three of them look like they jack off
Non-Stop and there's like one cool guy
laughs
and the cool guy in their presence it
makes the other guys look way not that
cool that's such a funny way to judge
people it's a funny way to look at the
world
I get it what about what about the uh
the farthest eyeball popped do you guys
remember that oh yeah yeah that's cool I
guess okay I guess that's a jack off
move someone can pop them out hell up
far yeah so that record because I
remember seeing that when I was a lot
younger right um but that record just
got broken really whoa because I
remember there was was it a black dude
that used to always do that because I
remember it was a black dude remember
that 90s TV show that was all Guinness
yeah well I remember that check this out
this is the new world oh my oh [ __ ]
that's way crazier than the black dude
because the black dude's eyes could pop
out far yeah that [ __ ] looks like a
Halloween mask that's like holding them
in your like you know when you you're
messing around as a kid it's his
expression as well at what point did
they like actually fall off yeah oh so
the way this guy describes it first and
foremost is he also like when he does it
he loses his sight for a few seconds so
that anybody said it always comes back
though he doesn't get 360 camera sites
until it doesn't bro that the stuff with
eyes I get really scared you know what's
crazy his face is so crazy his face is
so crazy I can't even tell how much he
jacks off
the result of like some kind of a
problem like a thyroid is a thyroid or
some kind of like glandular thing can
every person do it no it's like you have
to have that yeah I think it's like
genetic it's like a pro it's like a bad
thing how do you figure out if you have
so it says the actual scientific term
for being able to see a hot babe that's
how you find out yeah awuga it's called
the awuga you see Jessica Rabbit
yeah so the actual scientific term uh is
called Globe luxation okay and measuring
the pop is a tricky task which needs to
be done by an optometrist using a
special device called a proptometer they
made a device just for that yeah
probably for injuries but basically I
mean when we're talking about uh the the
former world record holder was actually
uh she her name is Kim Goodman she could
pop her eyes out 0.47 inches whereas
this guy goes to 0.71 inches well I
thought the former world record went to
the guy that fought Kimbo
[Laughter]
see that's scary I'm not messing yeah he
says he could pop his eye out for about
30 seconds but the few drawbacks are
being able to stick your eyes so far out
of your head that like he loses sight
for a few seconds but as a part of trick
it always comes back so he just feels
comfortable with it yeah what if it
doesn't though exactly oh that's all it
takes he does the trick then they'll
just take off they'll just extend the
rest of his face forward he just has to
go back in you know oh I mean that's
like that's like real life X-Men [ __ ]
here's another photo
um yeah is there a profile yeah look at
the mirror
for Brazil bro yeah you think he likes
acai what do you think that's when you
get him at a Chokehold in Brazilian Jiu
Jitsu that's how he learned his friends
and family call him Uncle Fester he does
like Uncle Fester Fester wishes dude
eyes just [ __ ] dry out dude yeah bro
do you guys actually have you ever read
into a like a Guinness world of record
like have you read the book like looked
into it as a kid I remember when I was a
kid I was like just I'm like
now or like yeah okay well remember when
they were like Gleek or from their eye
and then see how far that could go and
that's a distance measurement or like
the [ __ ] noodle through your like the
magic tricks how that's all connected I
remember people would do like longest
makeout longest kiss or something like
that that's not a talent like exactly
it's like what is this dude what are we
doing here yeah it's still kind of
oppressive but it's still like but why I
think the longest plank was like over 24
hours yeah it was that Marine guy right
yeah I think David Goggins broke the
pull-up record oh yeah yeah he he
yeah he did and that one's crazy the
plank one because uh they gotta still
like pee in [ __ ] and stuff so they got
like [ __ ] catheters in and stuff oh I
think it should be things that you're
just born with that you didn't have to
work for I think that should be yeah
like like the tallest man yeah yeah like
largest inheritance yeah
I don't know about achievements like
those are you worked so hard for it that
should be something else like the the
useless Olympics or something you
remember the uh the fingernails there
was a the guy that would do the longest
fingernails usually from India those are
crazy yeah they're usually from India
like either Indian lady or Indian uh
woman or man so what do you do what do
you do for the rest of your day like
they talked about that with the long
fingernail ones that that stuff would be
like you wouldn't be able to sleep for a
long period of time because you're on
would fall asleep so like his spouse
would have to like every 15 minutes
[ __ ] move his hand every 15 minutes
it was some [ __ ] like that well he just
needs one of those headsets to work at
the call center so he doesn't have to
worry about his hands that much or
there's that other dude who like guests
will record for like keeping his hand
raised
and then he has like muscle like you
know developments that are obviously
nerd dude if you have the record for
doing this as long as you can go play
imagine if you had that determination
and you did something else do you guys
know anyone with a Guinness record no
you you do spin boy yeah the guy in my
crew he has the goodness for head spins
see that's pretty [ __ ] but what's
what's the actual record like longest
200 like it goes by rotations yeah after
you stop touching the ground didn't you
say he specifically has a thing with his
ear or something yeah he has like some
kind of inner ear Advantage where he
doesn't uh get busy in in balance from
being dizzy wow his fluid always stays
even or something and he's just you
could just spend 200 times so that's the
cool thing about him is he goes uh so he
will break his record right and then
he'll allow someone to break it because
he only he knows his max
so he he's not going to break it by a
hundred spins because someone else will
go after that so he'll go he'll break it
by the minimum and let someone break it
and then break it again that's so cool
yeah he doesn't want anybody to know
what is what the most he's ever done
really is what's your guy do you guys
have a weird thing that you guys know
you could do
that you didn't work for that's just
like this is a thing that you could
check this out what
oh you can move your ears no what this
whole time Nick the ear that's pretty
cool dude that's really good I can't
move my ears I need [ __ ] Focus bro I
need I need to [ __ ] what are you
flexing yeah what do you feel when you I
don't know I feel like I'm just pulling
my scalp back wait Lucha
nope no don't you [ __ ] think about it
dude you'll never be me
you can't do it I have nothing the only
thing I have for stretchy earlobes but
it doesn't though it's really stretchy
you can't really do anything with that I
was always jealous of the kids that
could do this the flip it yeah and then
chase you around I feel like taika has a
picture of him doing that probably is
crazy [ __ ] I randomly remember I could
just do this thing with my knuckle and I
was like this is interesting
and then I'm like it's actually not that
interesting it just doesn't do anything
functional or cool does it hurt no but
it just literally like pops over the
knuckle socket what the [ __ ] it is loud
yeah it's not easy having a perfect body
that doesn't malfunction on you
Pinnacle of male Humanity what do you
think would be like the most [ __ ]
exciting Guinness World Records probably
just like the longest longest someone
going there probably is the longest dick
like I bet you there's a in Guinness
World Record do you think there's a guy
who has to like with the clipboard
button come up yeah look it up longest
dick
I remember seeing an interview with that
guy laptop and he's like really
miserable he says yeah there's a point
there's a length of Dick where you
apparently your life goes downhill like
this I think it's longer than that
because you can't even use it yeah it's
not just that black guy that sits
sitting on the bed that's so sad uh you
gotta find a woman with an equally deep
Canal yeah because that's probably not
is that a thing I don't hear much I
thought you just make every woman have
the the canals yeah yeah find deepest
Canal yeah I like I like how I want to
actually go to Guinness World Records
and you look for longest penis the first
thing that pops up is longest animal
penis and then it shows a blue whale
pretty big because a [ __ ] loser put
that entry Hey Big Ups to that blue
whale yeah yeah that's tight that's
tight shout out bro
18.9 inches
18.9 inches
[Music]
[Music]